hello guys I'm Ryan right not wearing my
B today and uh Oh Jimmy just was robbed
he did it did it you made it man
B the most electrifying man in movie
review entertainment on you - way to go
white people out of you congratulations
man so oh this is a long-ass video oh
really want to react a lot well yeah we
can and we just wanna you can what I
make whatever edits need to do that's
all while we just uh I'll take two
hundred man take so long see what he has
to say winkle nowhere how did we get
here like that's the question right now
um I'm a you guys certainly deserve a
thank you video I'm gonna try to keep
this between I don't want to jump cut
the [ __ ] out of this one just want to
keep it you know Maggie mean I always
fans and keep it all pure but a million
subscribers just happen for those of you
who don't know I just hit 1 million
subscribers that's it's a lot of
subscribers it's almost an unfathomable
unquantifiable amount that you can
actually quantify a lot of people have
asked me my story and how would it did
starting youtube some people want to see
my filming room ooh that makes me
nervous I know it's like some people
just the regular guy behind do great
nice rezoning like that which those
those douchey for me to say but in my
head I don't know how you guys thought
that that would be a good idea you
should do it cool [ __ ] um it really gave
me a pat when I didn't have a path I was
a projection Center movie theater
frustrated because you see so many
people and find the groove in their life
like oh that's totally what I'm gonna do
and there I was starting movies in a
digital theater that didn't need to have
me there but the boss was cool the
company was cool so they they were like
it'll keep Jeremy as a projectionist but
I was kind of mine as a shredded YouTube
my friends never like we're going to
make short films gonna be awesome
and so we made a couple and it's a
grueling process it really is just hard
it's difficult and sometimes quite
horrendous and so I wasn't having fun
doing it so we didn't do it anymore
because we were just getting stressed
out and angry at each other for zero
reason whatsoever but I had this camera
and my friends were like you should go
to YouTube that was like I'm not that
interesting I don't know what you guys
are smoking but don't think that I'm
that fascinating um so I didn't do it
and then I thought Transformers Revenge
of the Fallen transformer thick-set Iman
had a YouTube channel called movie man
191 and I just so didn't like
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen I was
like I think I'm gonna talk about that
on YouTube give me an excuse to use my
huge overpriced camera so why not I'm in
credit card debt because of the camera
so why not so set it up and I actually
did a thing where I talked about Star
Trek x-men origins Wolverine and
transformers ruins of the following cut
it together and put it up didn't tell
anyone that I did I just wanted to see
what people said and people were kind
about it was good that was funny you
know very kind words from the get-go
which is super cool because I know how
demoralisation can get I have to assume
there are people you started YouTube who
got some [ __ ] you you don't know and
then they just stopped which is sucks
it's a tragedy I got the end YouTube
you've got to have thick skin which I've
done in Wisconsin get custard in the
common hitter or the comment section in
my videos it happens and I totally get
it
um and if it happens early on I get that
people will probably stop doing it which
I'm sorry if that's happened to you but
uh so I didn't tell anyone about it
somehow people at my work found out
about it and they just clicked but found
my channel found the review turned it on
while I was there and I was like this is
the other going to inspire me to do more
videos or I'm going to stop as of now
and they were they were all laughing my
former boss still defense that's his
favorite video I've ever done so I got I
got lucky in that sense and just I mean
it was just really was a cycle of really
positive reading words had was having
fun doing I still having fun doing it
then look six and a half
years I happily six-and-a-half years of
seeing people do it quicker I've seen
people do it slower but we got there but
it still is a hobby like I tell people
people like what do you do for a job I'm
like I don't have a job I have a hobby
that get money from that I'm done I'm
pretty much unemployment it's not
employee than PI but figuring on oh yes
I talked about we are main channels um
as you laughter that just kept doing it
and that first hundred subscribers is
the biggest Heil ever feel on YouTube
it's that first time you see the digits
go holy [ __ ] and that's why 1 million is
my board because it's very much the same
feeling it's a milestone because that
first hundred you're like oh I'm gonna
do this on it oh I'm gonna keep doing
this and now a million it's not the end
it's not like an end solid moving piece
no a millions word it continued millions
kind of like the Master Sword and Zelda
where it's like alright you've got that
thing now we've only just begun and then
your adventure starts from there
that's a Link to the Past for people who
might not get the right reason that's
not an ocarina that's our guru knows the
best um
if anyone wants to start YouTube reviews
or YouTube whatever my only advice is
have fun be yourself and be honest cuz
your integrity is everything on here do
you start bullshitting people they're
gonna see they're not dumb um I smoke
marijuana just it's the sincerity that
you'll come with will be why people
watch you since errand and one thing
also is people seem to think that
YouTube is it get-rich-quick scheme it's
not oh so I'm very like oh we're gonna
get quick money on YouTube doesn't work
that way and if you go into it with that
mindset you're just gonna get frustrated
I had no idea that was a thing and so
from personal experience again I kind of
like took the route it was ignorance and
bliss I just didn't know that you can
make money doing YouTube so I did I just
did it because for the shave it because
it was fun and yeah it's really cool
seeing the feedback you're talking to
the people people who would respond to
you're like what are you talking about
dude I it is remarkable how
people seem to think like I've met fans
and it's almost like they react like
they're meeting a celebrity to me in
life I don't know why you're reacting
that hard it's awesome and I appreciate
it
it might feel better like geek out of
anybody
so just others literally watching the
Food Network downstairs in my house
where we are filming this is my bedroom
I like finish it but I'm going back and
if the magic is happening yeah my my
surroundings so if you're gonna do this
do it as a hobby first and if you get
money crazy fun chat script I remember
he sent them to those what helped me
have money thank you from the bottom of
my heart seriously you guys like I said
gave me something to get me it's kind of
sounds super cheesy it gave me a legacy
like it gave me a legacy worth having it
gave me something worth working towards
every week and that's the thing about it
that makes it great is that I don't have
to really scrape for [ __ ] and run out of
ideas it's like every week I get to talk
about movies which is really funny
because uh I do a couple people when I
was younger um one person in particular
was like you know little beaker close
watching sis one neighbor he was like
movie critics people who talk about
movies for a living they think that is
anything worth doing there sadly
mistaken and now I'm doing this and he's
like good job man super awesome this is
really funny
they should kind of change just like
that when you have different perspective
but I'm gonna do something that really
makes me nervous cuz I feel vulnerable
it literally is like seeing me naked is
kind of how to film a lot just you DJ
guys no Jeremy don't do that guys want
to see where I film so let's see where I
film sort of riot no way it's gonna be
quiet because I think there might be
some people editing in there or uh
filming possibly so his header game was
living quite interesting Hey hello
anyone there when the oh there's not Stu
says I don't haven't headed
no one else new films I just talk all
right this is the room this is where the
magic really happens I think that's my
clear even carpeted bedroom and walk out
the echo it is sort of these lights are
climbing help to have a room dedicated
to filming yeah looking at it a light
that lights me as I'm standing there two
lights that like the green screen green
screens like 40 bucks on Amazon so
miscellaneous [ __ ] over here have like a
bunch of bulbs because bulbs wear out
and you just want to have them all so I
think I literally went there and bought
every both the head he just hasn't
managed and honor laptops I got some
weird pops that I've used I used that
for terminator
there's my tour de force pipe yeah a gun
for when the movies really get back and
my do doesn't my Coppola where's your
murder the most anything yeah so I'm
talking about like oh that's it's uh
Mike still Oh Star Wars curtain cake you
cannot forget that reminds us all what's
awesome but uh
oh no lint roller because later Mike and
you need to were
need to fix that but here I'll show you
what it takes to make a video that my
great love in Corbin rounds if I keep
looking for this amazing cuz like
carpeted rooms are like everywhere in
New Jersey
he has the exact setup I want just like
that that's how you make a youtube video
and I I'm doing this to show you guys
well first of all you know what strong
we can the course like a now in nothing
but hold on I want to get it stopped
whoa took way too long
that's why did you jump cuts ladies and
gentlemen but no I wanted to show you
guys this because I mention there's some
people out of work oh I can't start
YouTube I don't have a budget clearly
neither do why I have no budget
whatsoever I'm zero budget
um one can argue I have a budget now but
you know already has this camera camera
is like a thousand bucks tripod grinders
and tripods pretty expensive but I
started sharing from the laptop I would
get a nice expensive $100 um the zoom
h4n the little audio thing that's what
he has Wow 300 the microphones 300 to
games looking into that [ __ ] the light
set is $300 green screens like 45 um but
that he's actually probably retirement
you can do whatever so what one time
purchase of all that stuff and I was
able to do YouTube until now my gear is
unchanged except the audio equipment and
the the camera the rest of this [ __ ]
same stuff of always use up same setup I
have always used but I do it to show you
that you don't need a lot you don't need
everything let me this huge budget you
don't need backing you don't need a crew
you see you as you want to do it just do
it because apparently that excuse of
like will they don't have a lot of money
is now gone I've taken that from you I'm
really sorry about that but you you no
longer have that anything if it's not
YouTube it's something else I'm just
showing you that if one guy can get
million people to watch him or approach
consistent with 300,000 people haha
anything you want to do - you don't need
everything you get it as you go so just
do it do that thing you know it's just
that is the reason I showed you this
room and the show goes free because is
it underwhelming absolutely and it
should be because just normal people
doing normal thing I don't know if
YouTube videos are normal we hit a
million and so I have no intention of
stopping so there would probably be a
two million video I'm always like out
the gate I'm like my channel remains the
same unchanged untouched as if this
other thing isn't happening and some
companies would well I'm like well you
can kindly go [ __ ] yourself so assume
they went had sex with themselves was
like no content creator first is what he
always said sack and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more thank you for clicking right
here to see more for so long so many
times cisco Walker I love ya goddammit
that's probably my favorite video of his
that's pretty damn that was probably my
favorite
it's so cool to get his like perspective
in his philosophy like his mentality on
things and this is very similar to ours
yeah it just goes back like Tyrone and I
have like studied a lot of like personal
development motivational whatever you
want to call them those kind of speakers
and books and such one thing that really
stood out to me one of the biggest
quotes I ever heard was to be successful
study success it got me to realize a lot
of successful people kind of have the
same mentality and attitude towards
things and sure enough makes sense why
is that a million subscribers same
things I've learned and heard it's like
I don't know if he did personal
development I don't know if you got
there naturally but damn it's so
reassuring to hear like everything I've
worked my mind and heart to is pretty
much what he's saying to do and I agree
with so much in here that's true that's
true do not disagree with anything that
man
one of the best pieces of advice that I
got when I start doing my channel
because I'll be honest I didn't watch
any YouTube channels I hadn't even heard
screen junkies at the time but I came
across Jeremy Jones as I was like typing
in movie critics and I got hooked on his
videos I got really hooked on them and I
came across a video when I was
considering starting youtuber he said
make sure that if you do it that you're
treated as a hobby first because YouTube
there was a time arose about the
sketches and stuff it was about all that
yeah now it's probably like people like
who can upload daily and who can upload
like at least every other day or some
[ __ ]
treating it like a hobby I do feel is
important because that's what keeps you
loving it and that love will translate
to the camera and it keeps you connected
to the fans and stuff it's so important
to treat as a hobby first it's like be
aware you're making money off of it be
aware that it's also your own business
but primarily should be the love for it
right right right um my my philosophy
was slightly different mine was more
like because I had picked it up as kind
of a side route to um an acting career I
had totally gone broke
going on all types of auditions he I
rivaling at Athens screen tests and
shows and I was at a wit's in I didn't
have any rich parents to cart me around
all my auditions you know and I had
heard that there were people that had
carved a niche for themselves created a
personality on YouTube and then been
discovered that way yeah and to do other
things so for me because I'd already set
my mind on being an actor being an
entertainer when I started YouTube I was
like alright let me check this up me try
a couple of videos people like me this
is going to be my career until there is
another career so mine was a little
different but the same principle is that
I treat it as fun yeah I'm gonna mean a
hobby should be fun for you okay I
didn't want it to be a job I wanted to
be something that was painstakingly dull
or you know I was just grueling and I
had to grind that every
I know I wanted it to always be fun and
that's exactly what it is so the spirit
of hobby was always yeah with me
creating a career on you they should be
part of the core I agree is that's
that's where I was coming from to I had
been doing everything and writing and
acting and then when I came across
YouTube I had never seen you - I saw the
business model at YouTube right which
was one thing that a lot of successful
financial people teach you is residual
income yes and yes that word with it and
YouTube offers multiple streams of
income you could get product placement
and make money off Adsense the number
one thing I thought was wow wait a
minute YouTube is global there's
millions of millions of people on it I'm
going to get a few thousand who like me
here attaboy a million so if I could
just get a few thousand that might
generate me enough attention where I
don't have to keep trying to get my
[ __ ] foot in the door instead of you
holes coming move yeah and that's
happening for both of us yeah now the
biggest years I've worked for were
Warner Brothers and legendary like to
regularly work with them and they're
pretty big city ISM [ __ ] awesome
sometime accident [ __ ] sexy one thing
I was I said in one video in a lot of
people like the way he just talked about
the residual income is one thing I used
to look at with stocks and you know
looking at properties as you know
residual income and that's how I look at
the videos each video is a small
investment you know people would make
residual income make money while they
sleep you know and that's how it is you
know even the biggest stars in the world
you make a movie but you can't pay these
royalties you know you're sleeping and
your movie is still making you money and
making you a living and something you
love as a passion that you have you know
what I mean and that's what he's doing
and I greatly appreciate that he really
went out of his way to mention that it's
not something that happens overnight
exactly you know and it's it's true it
doesn't I remember on my older years
dude yeah oh my oh my old Instagram I
posted the first 50 Cent's I [ __ ]
hate 50 cents and it's about as far as I
went
I tell you let me ask you this the first
time you got a check from Google wasn't
it like oh it's trippy looks like this
is working making money finally mean
I've spent a lot of money on because
because this channel started off with
just movie reviews and there wasn't any
reaction reviews or anything so I was
spending not just the equipment the lot
because we had a green screen I still
have I just don't really use it I got
the lights I got the camera the mic
laptop I didn't have a laptop so I threw
down a lot of money and you know what I
was doing to make money at that time I
just talking with Tyrone about this um I
was donating plasma
it'd be like $35 you could only donate
twice a week
$35 the one time then the second time of
the week 45 so you see in the movie yeah
that's why I started the guy ends up
being like a superhero later but tiffany
is still a plasma you know not such [ __ ]
yeah by the time eventually throughout
the prostituting YouTube my job upgraded
but when I started off with YouTube like
buying equipment and [ __ ] I was a lot of
[ __ ] money there was a lot of blood I
didn't you know like you can still see
the track mark like right there well
right here you see that always [ __ ] yeah
look like actually there yeah but you
think your plasma went to save someone's
life true Cheers and they paid me to do
it it's not an overnight thing and I
feel I feel like nothing is an overnight
thing unless you win the lottery but
that's why a lot of people don't keep
the money when they win the lottery
because success is a growth it's a
journey and it's a character-building
process to be able to handle such
success like if someone just gave me
three hundred fifty thousand subs I
would be like I don't know to do when
you earn your way there you know how to
handle it if the organic process of
learning and adjusting to what you're
doing because what I love about Jeremy
Jones is attitude of when I'm really
seeing is he tries to make this feel
less like business as much as possible
in the sense that he doesn't ever want
to sacrifice his integrity or his uh the
ability to run what he
as because people have offered him TV
shows and he said no because he wants to
be his own boss right now sticking by
the integrity you have and I totally
agree
I have TV show ideas but I wouldn't want
this specific channel and stuff I
feature here to be on a TV because it's
meant for YouTube and it allows me to be
my own boss and have control over it in
my mindset as far as what he said about
having your own boss and stuff like that
successful people for multiple streams
of income and whatever it is that they
do so I feel like the YouTube channel is
always gonna be something I have I mean
with me being a voice-over artist you
know a an actor also model hey I'm going
to potentially have bosses and whatever
is that I do if I you know take other
steps but I can always come back to
where I begin exactly you know exact
idea boss or working for Hollywood or
whatever I can always come back it's
always gonna be a constant anyway so you
guys always see Mike success as I
climbed the ladder and if things don't
work out for me and how it was not for
me I'll always be on you - yeah exactly
what Jeremy Jones was really saying was
he encouraged me to the point where I
was like you know what so many people
are after reaction channels right now if
we I got shut down I feel like I could
just start a new channel and throw my
way again maybe I won't boom and be
super fast be irritating but even I feel
like I just still do it you know your
name is big enough to where people if
you were shut down they're gonna be
looking for you like yeah we're all man
you got it down we know he's got another
channel before yeah exactly aren't you
good it does take a lot of the character
that he's talking about I've just do
what you love
follow your passion the most cliche is
one thing I was talking to Tyrone but
there's a podcast we did on Ian's
Gutowski channel you should go check it
out where we going to death it's like an
hour long and we go in-depth about a lot
of these things because I have a love
for movies that I could just transfer
into something else I've also learned
how to edit I've learned how to do a lot
of things that gather me this fortunate
success I have so I just got to apply
the same tools and it's all about the
fundamentals and you master the basics
you can pretty much excel anywhere with
YouTube it's theirs
it's simple people look at it a person
they go I don't
is it too much information you know but
if you just take time and you spend a
while on it it becomes a simple format
in the sense that it's easy yet you have
to work hard at it and you got to be
consistent at it and it's a [ __ ]
rocks man I think it's [ __ ] sweet oh
you know what I loved about this video
it felt like we were just hanging out
are you going in the middle meet are you
going in the middle meeting how rude
disrespectful so he said you liked it
good we were hanging out with him yeah
yeah it's cool because he always sort of
had like oh we're just hanging out with
a regular guy who's also a movie critic
but it was cool to just be like whoa
he's just filming and [ __ ] and we're
just inside of his room and yes yes I so
agree that it doesn't need to be as
complicated as people make it out to be
treu I've helped a lot of people almost
every honorary reject on this channel
I've helped so many of them start up
their channels and get it going and at
least get past a thousand subs because I
wanted to show them it's really not as
difficult as you might feel like it's
going to be it's kind of like that with
anything honestly you can get good at
anything if you really understand the
fundamentals that's true you get to a
point in your life where you're like if
I focus on something I'll probably be
able to figure it out you know just like
you know you start a new job you know
the beginning yeah a little rough but
you get to know everything and then it's
like okay you know yeah I'm just like
the back your hand yeah I'm saying that
because of the fact that I don't
Tyrone's channel on my channel we get a
lot of comments of people being like I
want to start my our channel or I'm
starting my own channel could I get some
advice and stuff it's the best advice I
can give you is it it's really simple
it's much more simple than you know and
I always say today be yourself and have
fun be yourself and have fun because
people want to buy you the biggest
complaint or thing that sets people back
that I hear a lot is kid but um is
already like say they want to be a movie
crate they'll say yeah but there's
already a ton of them out there so
embrace what makes you you exact and
it'll show people always like something
different yeah even though you do
something somebody else does
okay I mean they are buying your
difference yeah okay so keep that in
mind there's a ton there's a target ton
of burger joints out there in there okay
and a ton of them are all successful but
they all offer something different yeah
it makes them unique and that's what you
got to do yeah I don't walk into
McDonald's ago this is just like Burger
King right right right yeah we're seeing
some stuff that might sound cliche hate
to break it to you guys but all the
cliche lines come from those who are
successful yet finding out that all
these cliche lines are like screw the
more you climb the ladder and learn and
meet people you like oh like when stars
say I'm just like you you know a lot of
times you want to sit there and be like
yeah yeah yeah whatever ain't you and I
humble oh you yeah I get letters from
people and they you know they put me on
a pedestal sometimes and I'm just like
yo you understand I am just like you
like me and Tom Holland fanboy doubt for
each other you understand that we're
just we're regular people yeah it's okay
a man look at me Tyrell have you I was
the one who was excited to see him in en
la cama little little calm [ __ ]
sabaidee what I real just me number
three
yeah sure that he is just like me
cooking up everything like they really
aren't they eat they sleep they put
their pants on one leg at a time unless
you're a little different
Tom Holland only talked to you cuz he
knew who you were he didn't even look at
me cuz he thought I was a normal Joe who
was just like oh this is the friend to
the famous guy like I'm part of Tyrone's
entourage or something yeah that's what
he thought so
I disagree with Tom ball and not
thinking he's superior cuz you clearly
do Tom Holland you're 16 and it hurts my
feelings you're like a decade younger
than me and that you wouldn't even look
at me
respect your elders I'm gonna shout out
one please Tom just buy your buttery
cool
I think is that a lawyer please agree
he's great
let's see tamil is just like anybody
else you know sometimes he ignores
people by accident or yeah I guess one
piece of advice I would also give is
when he's talking about equipment and
stuff if you can't afford that start
from where you're at right when I start
doing reaction stuff I started just from
my laptop I didn't shoot with a camera
or lights it was just from my laptop and
now fortunately I've been able to
upgrade to a camera and microphone and
lights and [ __ ] so and most of us have
stumbled upon a channel where we saw a
title in the video quality just from the
thumbnail look shitty but then when you
start watching it you're like oh this
guy's good this girl yeah yeah and then
you continue to watch them for the
quality they bring if you're doing the
kind of thing we're like it's tyrone and
i or jeremy jones where you're
representing yourself and your thoughts
and opinions and all that what people
are gonna care most about is you not
assert of the quality of the video but
who you are and can they buy into you
and buy into what you're also saying
because when i first started this
channel i was so concerned like if you
watch the earlier videos I was like
analytical and I was technical I was I
was trying to make sure I came across
like I could fit in the movie community
then I got to a point where I'm like I
don't give a [ __ ] anymore I'm just gonna
be me yeah he's like louis c.k of movie
reviewers and uh people say I'm like
Deadpool the yell you are you are the
Deadpool death and I am [ __ ] dead
he's gonna be on us he's on screen
junkies he collaborates with them and
I'm gonna be on screen junkies on the
25th of February movie fights so tune in
for that people well yeah Jeremy Jones
congratulations on a million subscribers
you absolutely deserve it
hands down whenever I list my favorite
youtubers I always say you're number one
so if you're ever in California would
love to collaborate with you you're one
of my heroes man and I heard he was in
California I heard he was in California
I Terry it wasn't for him I wasn't for
me he gave me a prosperous
I'm leaving wonder if you're just like
tired all in all Jeremy Jones and Tom
hall would get along ignoring me cool
man
listen guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe today and I can't
remember who said this but someone said
I should call the fans and I'm changing
it to Royal rejects that is clever no
you don't like it real rejects Royal
rejects it kind of works because over
the real rejects so that I would call
the fans the rejects
so royal rejects why what's the Royal
cuz they're loyal keep image or is it
loyal rejects just keep it rejects yeah
sorry entire I'm Magnus as a channel
check out the Tyrone Magus channel I
wanted to give a shout out to the
schmoes now to promote ourselves we're
gonna be going I'm not doing a podcast
with them keep a lookout for that yes we
are and critic I've said for the longest
time who do you have to blow to go on
schmoes now I mean Mark Ellis supergirls
Ryan will do the blowing I've been out
just ago on this yet blue mark Ellison
Kristian harloff watched and laughed in
point it's kind of like that scene in
the hateful eight and Sam Jack oaken
Irma I thought it wasn't in the room no
okay that router is gone fun okay he
wasn't in the room yeah okay